hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to stealing the diamond the
delightful and charming game that you're
gonna enjoy no matter what so buckle up
anyway this game came out a while ago
and it involves stealing that diamond
there and we have to come up with an
ingenious way to do that twelve million
dollars well haha
my life's terrible so I might as well go
for it
alrighty then this game came out a while
ago on Newgrounds of maybe everyone else
on the Internet oh hello
Plus stand or sneak in and I never
really played it busting of course like
a boss role in raise hell steal things
what a scooter oh no please please stop
them kick grammar jump oh ok Wow I'm off
to a great start
you gotta use the keyboard for oh ok
fine then kick I didn't do me a lot of
good I don't know that's wait what are
the toys kik-kik
grammar jump ha that awesome didn't work
for me ok jumping off a speeding vehicle
may not be the best idea
well thanks game I don't know this I
haven't played it yet
Wow ok man now what do I do now they all
seem to know I'm here no you gotta help
me here
Jagga click on this one a barely Lance
[Music]
oh gods oh man this game is still
lightful this game is extremely highly
reviewed wherever you go it's shockingly
effective oh man now I don't know the
other oh hello wait
tokima I guess good yes nope they just
happen arrested him whoa really
yeah that's when I decided I should
probably get a different job I figured
that garden is much less dangerous than
driving well then did I win
oh I'm GTA now Oh
geek oh god you can't give me I'm not
ready I'm talking to my audience here
okay so ranch
I'm gonna work out great from the Wow
but I don't have the time and ya idiot
what are you doing alright well I don't
have time to think things through Jamie
give you a chance
three stars it seems bad now god damn it
sniper from tf2 your own adventure book
I love it
I'm spitting everywhere
bubbles that everyone carries around
especially for guys who have no job no
other way to do with them to steal a
diamond sir
place your hands where I can see them I
didn't think that through either yeah
I'm alive
maybe so where the hell am I gonna hock
this giant I won the aggressive way yeah
let's try the other ways this is so cool
how am I gonna sell that thing there's
no way anyone's gonna not know is that
turn eqh diamond I'm just gonna hump it
I'm just gonna hump it on this Beach
nobody watch this please okay sneak in
everybody be quiet
I'm trying to be oh my goodness so many
choices okay so these go up these go to
the left this seems like it's gonna end
horribly so let's try that first oh no
I'm going back I didn't know getting
points anti-gravity yes in a gravity cap
not a belt not boots
oh well space travel would be very
efficient if we all had that teleporter
ah it worked I think it worked you don't
see anything goodness oh I forgot I'm
not Captain Falcon Oh No oh wait no cap
I love the half-hearted voice acting
that they have in this thing Lee
tranquilizer yeah it seems logical oh no
I love his eyes this drifted steadily
apart like
[Music]
I would use it correct well wait what
happened it's hard to see when you're
invisible
what do you mean it's hard to see your
eyes are right then the same plate that
doesn't make any say you'd be totally
fine everyone else would have a problem
that's [ __ ] that's [ __ ] that's
[ __ ] penny
of course the low-tech Nene Wow
foes that fast in the first block I
wouldn't have drop straight in go for it
bro
all right I did think it was gonna work
screw you wire probably the best upset I
want to see what the portal gun would
have done though hammer that was a good
option how is that the good option okay
whatever I don't get the logic on can
yes oh no
Anand No
am i alive that seems like a maybe a
solid baby cheese I don't know you put
it as an option game how was I not
supposed to try it blank
Oh after that lady stopped and arrested
him whoa
really yeah okay snap neck like a badass
hit you game
I get you ha ha my neck
well Dimond oh he is very dead oh he is
so very dead I'm just gonna try the
other route that is available to me
which is the bottom route here going
straight in this way shrink-ray oh yeah
that was very dangerous
oh I'm sure this won't end horrible I
mean that cake and use the to escape and
then I got fired pretty lame huh
what there's no they wouldn't hear an
explosion there's a freakin bomb right
here I'm gonna use that
oh they're itchy trigger fingers gun oh
yeah why would it be loaded cuz I'm an
idiot oh shut up I don't want to hear
your story Oh Wayne why
oh why this is Bhavani grande exhibit or
the rest
waitwhat them oh I see
go now uh uh I don't know where I went
in the world
oh why didn't I walk well walking in
might have been a bad idea
pick your favorite game let's go half
life love half life those are headcrabs
for those that don't know super mushroom
bloop bloop bloop can't be a bat
everything can only turn out great
doesn't even hurt somehow being bigger
makes me immune to bullets
[Music]
I expected this all is just as logical
as what was happening okay well all
right then ouchies my dad better not be
dead what is going on in this insane
world somewhere in the Midwest center
for chaos containment chaos control
hey sir yeah might want to come look at
this no I got like it I'm getting chaos
readings at 1006 it's come from the
museum oh my god yeah yeah nine yeah I'm
leaving this decision after you go bro
just hit one of those buttons to deal
with this is a big situation - oh it is
I get I get to move my big grotesque
finger oh there's some divide by zero oh
god yes okay anyway enough of me
giggling like a fool
yeah the new action Call of Duty
reference what's the call of future
reference
oh well everything went green I don't
think that normally happens therefore
the mother also
oh my goodness whatever the hell this
thing is
[Music]
okay that seems to be just doing more
chaos why was that a good option can I
just grab the diamond please okay
indecisiveness will get you killed sir
yes thank you please move along oh my
god that's so awesome I know this is
just sick figures and all and it's
supposed to be silly but this is it's
really cool and well done I mean there's
a lot of animators that came out of this
whole online gaming era about I don't
know four or five years ago I don't
remember when this was released there's
another game made by this guy there's a
lot of games made by this guy then I
might play if you guys look love this
one I got the epic ending that's even
better than the aggressive one obviously
the undetected one is the most boring
but all of you guys liked it there's a
lot more stuff that I probably didn't
explore that you guys can find out for
yourself if you not played this game yet
I highly recommend it there's a lot of
unique deaths and items that I did not
get to use so check it out in the
description below and if you want to see
more from this guy or games like this
let me know in the comments below thanks
again everybody so much for watching and
as always I will see you in the next
video
[Music]